(gentle music)
- [Announcer] This season
on the Drew Barrymore Show.
One working girl takes on the world.
- You know, I have a head for business,
and a bod for sing-le breasted suits.
(jaunty jazz music)
- [Announcer] With her signature passion,
and appetite for life.
- This sandwich, it's so good!
It is so good!
It's the best sandwich I've ever had!
- I think I'll have one of those.
As a matter of fact, can
you make it a double?
(upbeat jazzy theme music)
- [Announcer] Whether you're a Miranda
looking for her Steve,
or just a slice of pizza.
- Cheers, I love you.
- I love you.
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] This season will leave you
sleepless with excitement.
Thanks to a little help
from the Drew Crew.
- It's you.
- It's me.
- [Announce] Starring
interior designer Mikel Welch.
Chef Pilar Valdes.
Co-anchor Ross Mathews.
And host Drew Barrymore.
In the Drew Barrymore Show.
Season two.
- Welcome home.
(upbeat music)
- [Drew] It's week two
of our premiere event!
Back in New York City.
With celebrities!
It is really hard to
contain my excitement.
New York's best bites.
Plus, Evan Hanson meets Josie Grossie!
And today on Drew,
Fran Drescher surprises Awkwafina!
The two queens of Queens.
It all starts now.
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] Please
welcome Drew Barrymore.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- Hi hi!
(Drew laughing)
Oh my God, thank you, thank you.
I don't-
I don't know if anyone got a glimpse
of the beginning of season one,
but I went real hard by myself here.
I looked nuts.
We were all nuts.
It was September of 2020.
We had this really intimate setting,
and yet one day we hoped
that maybe we could ever get here.
So to our very first New
York studio audience,
thank you so much!
(audience applause)
Thank you, thank you so much.
(audience cheering)
It's a total dream.
One I never thought we'd get to,
but here we are in our season two,
and it is such a privilege to be back
in my new hometown of New York.
I love it here so much.
(audience applause)
I don't know if you can
tell from my accent,
but I'm from California.
(audience laughing)
And we're just celebrating
everything about hometowns.
We kicked off in my
hometown of Los Angeles,
and we're here now, and you know,
I just want to celebrate the whole country
and celebrate the fact that
there is no place like home.
And that emotional storytelling for me
is gonna be a huge thread for this season.
And we actually get to leave the studio.
So I want to take it as far vast and wide
as they'll possibly let us,
and here we are, starting in New York.
And our first guest couldn't be more true
to the storytelling and the
thematic nature of New York
because she hails from Queens.
She is a rapper, a Golden Globe winner,
and you know, superstar from like,
blockbuster hits like "Crazy Rich Asians."
I know!
(audience cheering)
Isn't that the best movie ever?
I have seen that movie 50 times.
She's in the amazing movie "Farewell,"
for which she won a Golden Globe.
And she's most recently
in the number one film across
the entire globe, "Shang-Chi."
So, I know.
(audience applause)
Her star just continues to rise,
and you can catch her on
her show on Comedy Central,
which I love so much, "Nora From Queens."
Take a look.
- We are hot.
- I look more like Owen
Wilson than I do Cameron Diaz.
- Selfie!
- Who's gonna take it?
- Oh.
- Okay we literally
don't have time for this.
We have 23 stops tonight, let's go.
- How many stops?
- 23!
- (laughing) I love it!
(audience applause)
Please welcome Awkwafina!
- Yeah! What's up!
Hey!
- Hello!
- Hi Drew!
Yes!
- Oh my God.
I love this.
- New York in the building.
- Right! I mean, Queens!
You are a queen, and you're from Queens.
That's fitting.
- Yeah, appreciate that.
That's good.
- You know,
another queen from Queens,
is Lucy Liu.
And I wanted to ask you,
because Lucy had meaning
for you back in the day,
and I would just love
to hear from you, like,
what that was because I
love her and I love you,
and so I'm like, in the middle,
just wanting to know how
that story came about.
- Lucy Liu was, and "Charlie's Angels,"
was like the pinnacle of
like, everything to me,
and to see Lucy in a role like that
was really momentous.
It changed the way that I
looked at myself and the world.
And I will say that I don't think
that I would be where I am, truly,
without seeing Lucy Liu do
her thing back in the day.
It's good.
- When I watch "Nora From Queens,"
and your storytelling is so strong,
the way, you know, humor
to me has to have heart.
It's like, but I want humor to push.
How do you have the bravery
to push that humor so far,
'cause you go there.
You don't compromise.
You're such a badass.
- You know, I agree.
I think all humor needs to have
kind of heart at its baseline.
A lot of the things that
I talk about in my show
are a mixture of reality or like,
what I would imagine, you know,
my family or what they would say.
So I try to stick to that.
- What's so amazing is in
that very same episode,
you will break my heart,
and make me emotional, you know,
when you talk about your grandma.
And you did grow up in
Queens with your grandma.
And will you tell us about
that time of your life?
- She was definitely not, you know,
your ordinary parent.
I think, like, you know,
she really kind of
noticed the spunk in me,
and I remember I always
used to ask her, like,
I feel weird, grandma.
I feel like I don't fit in.
I feel like, you know,
people think certain things about me,
and I just feel weird.
And she always told me
the weirdness in you
is inevitably what's
gonna make you different
and what's gonna make you special.
She always told me that.
You know, she was always a big fan,
but she was also, you know,
like we got into shenanigans together
as well, you know.
There was a carnival that would
come to town, for instance,
and she didn't want to
pay the admissions fee.
So they gave out these bracelets
with little designs on them.
And she was like, let's just
buy a marker and white paper,
and I'll just tape it to your arm,
and we'll make your admission bracelet,
so I don't gotta pay like
ten bucks to get you in.
(laughing)
- I love that story so much.
And isn't it true when you were like 16,
she also told you something?
- She'd be like, you're ten years old
so that we can go to the buffet
and you can get a child discount.
(audience laughing)
And she literally would like,
slap a backwards cap on me, and it's like,
what is a backwards cap
just code for I'm a kid?
- Yes.
- But it worked.
- Okay.
(audience applause)
Another total juxtaposition with something
I was hoping that you could
share with our audience
because I just thought
it was such a hot tip,
and we could all benefit from it.
It's a beauty tip that you
gave to Allure Magazine
with your gorgeous cover that
was so unique and dynamic.
- Thank you, absolutely.
So if you ever need a makeup blotter,
or like a face blotter,
just go to any airport,
and just take a toilet seat cover.
Because that's what that is.
(audience laughing)
Yes, girl!
Yes, you could put your
head through it, too.
That's a necklace.
- It's true, you could.
- Yes, girl.
(audience laughing)
- And then you could actually-
- And make it fashion.
- And then...
- There you go.
And it's a bib!
- You changed my life with this tip,
so I just want to thank you.
'Cause I'm never looking at
these suckers the same way.
(audience laughing and clapping)
We're gonna go to a quick
commercial break, if that's okay.
And when we come back, I'd like to play
a little game with you, Awkwafina.
Beautiful Nora.
- I would love.
- With someone else who's a
very special Queens native,
and I'm very excited about this.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)
(audience applause)
I thought you should play against
another true blue Queens native.
Please welcome the
legendary Fran Drescher.
(audience applause)
- Yes!
- I'm so happy to be included
in this Queen of Queens game!
- Oh god!
- I love you so much!
(audience applause)
(upbeat music)
- We're back with the amazing, iconic,
and totally dope Awkwafina.
And in honor of "Nora
From Queens" and Awkwafina
being from Queens,
I thought that maybe we could
play a little trivia game
to test how much you really
know about your hometown.
You game?
- Yeah.
- Alright.
- I really hope I know
about my hometown, yeah.
- It's a little game we're
calling "Queen of Queens."
(audience applause)
(bright music)
Now, since I'm not from Queens,
I thought you should play against
another true blue Queens native.
Please welcome the
legendary Fran Drescher.
(audience applause)
- Yes!
Oh my, oh. Wow.
- Hi, everyone!
- I can't believe I'm here right now.
(audience laughing)
- I love both you girls!
I'm so happy to be included in
this "Queen of Queens" game.
- I love you so you much!
- Oh God!
I'm in like, I'm in a
"Queen of Queens" sandwich.
- Awkwafina, I should be
your neighbor on the show!
- Yes!
(laughing)
I'm sending the offer right now.
The offer's coming.
(audience laughing)
- Yay!
(audience applause)
- Oh my god, wow.
- Maybe it's the Love
Connection that we're playing.
- Awkwafina from Queens, I mean,
you're carrying the torch, girl.
And I'm really, really thrilled.
- Oh, thank you.
Where in, can we break away from,
where in Queens are you?
- Flushing!
- You're from Flushing!
That's crazy.
(audience laughing)
Did you go to Lum's?
- Of course!
That's where my sister's sweet 16 was.
- What! No way!
(audience applause)
That's my family's restaurant!
That's so cool.
- Really?
OMG, when I come to Queens, we should go.
- Yes, yes.
Yes, oh my god, so cool.
- By the way, Fran,
I was reading something
that you said once.
Is it true that like,
one television executive
said to you, like,
your voice, I don't know.
And then another person was like,
it's because of you, your
voice, your personality,
that this is gonna work.
- Yes, actually, you know, I mean,
all along the road,
people said that the voice
was going to hold me back.
And it was Peter Jacobsen,
my writing producing partner
and my beloved gay
ex-husband who said, uh uh,
that's, you know, the voice, the face,
the comic timing, that's
what's gonna make you a star.
And we're gonna lean into it.
We're not gonna try and dilute it
or move away from it.
And he was right, you
know, I'm really grateful.
But back in the day when we
had sold the idea for the show,
they actually said,
"Can the character be
Italian and not Jewish?"
- [Drew] Right.
And you said no.
- And yeah we,
we said no, because you know,
we couldn't write it as authentically.
I know how to be Jewish.
We know how to write Jewish.
(audience laughing)
That's the way we have to go,
and I kind of just, even though
I knew it was my big break,
we said, you know, no,
because I don't like to have regret.
And I thought, if I go along
with this idiotic suggestion
and it doesn't fly,
I'm gonna be kicking myself.
Why did I listen to them?
So you know, I just kind
of make it a cardinal rule
that I go with my gut,
and I try and convince everybody
why I think it's the right idea.
Rather than have to play it, please.
- Well I thank you both
for putting out shows
authentic to who you are,
and changing the world
to welcome other people
to find that confidence and do the same.
So thank you for that, seriously.
- Thank you.
(audience applause)
Yeah, we always had, thank you.
- And, so your origin
story starts in Queens.
We're gonna play a game.
You guys are gonna take
turns answering questions
with multiple choice options,
and the person with the
most correct answers
wins the "Queen of Queens."
Let's get to it.
The first question goes to Awkwafina.
Awkwafina, what famous magician
is buried in a cemetery in Queens?
Is it A, David Copperfield,
B, William Ellsworth Robinson,
C, magicians can't always be
put in a box, they can escape,
or D, Harry Houdini.
- I want to say Houdini,
but I feel like it might
be Copperfield, or C.
Oh god, the magicians
are gonna come after me.
The magicians are gonna come, Houdini.
- Okay, well it's Harry Houdini.
- Okay it's Harry Houdini!
It's Harry Houdini.
(audience applause)
(bright music)
- Oh, look.
She's got crowns falling from the sky.
Okay Fran, what neighborhood of Queens
did Cindy Lauper grow up in?
Was it Ozone Park, A,
B, Jackson Heights,
C, girls just want to have Flushing,
or D, Sunnyside?
- I'm gonna say Ozone Park.
(bell dings)
- You are right!
(audience applause)
- Whoa, whoa, yes, yes!
Yes!
- Okay, Awkwafina.
Which one of these people of note
was not born in Queens?
A, Howard Stern,
B, Tony Danza,
C, Lori Laughlin,
or D, Al Roker.
- Oh, oh man.
I almost want to say, Howard Stern,
but I don't know, I don't know.
Can I have a lifeline?
(audience laughing)
Can I take a lifeline?
Fran, what do you think?
Who do you think it is?
- I think your first instincts are right.
I'm gonna say Howard Stern.
- Well, you'll both be interested to know
it's B, Tony Danza.
(buzzer buzzing)
He was not born in Queens.
- [Fran] Oh.
- He was born in Brooklyn.
Okay, Fran's turn.
Which subway line runs through Queens?
A, the 6 Train,
B, the D Train,
C, the A Train,
D, IDK.
- I'm gonna guess the D.
No?
(Buzzer buzzing)
- It is the A train.
- The A Train goes to Queens?
- Apparently.
- It does, it goes.
- Alright.
The score is tied.
- It has been a while
since I've taken the subway.
(audience laughing)
You know, I've been stuck
in a train car with fans.
There's no way out, you know.
(audience laughing)
- No, no.
- Yeah, yeah.
Okay the last question goes to Awkwafina.
What part of Queens did
The Nanny take place in?
A, Astoria,
B, Forest Hills,
C, Flushing,
D, Drescher Island.
(audience laughing)
- C, right?
- Yes! Yes!
(bell dings)
- Yes!
- Flushing, you got it!
(audience applause)
- Thank you.
- I'm the flashy girl from Flushing.
- The flashy girl from
Flushing, the nanny named Fran.
- Well, the accumulative
winner is Awkwafina today.
But you are both queens,
two amazing queens,
who have changed the world.
(audience applause)
- Three queens, three queens.
- Awkwafina and Fran Drescher,
I am so honored to be in your
Queens sandwich right now.
- Thank you.
- And may we all be able
to come together again
as soon as possible.
"Nora From Queens" wednesdays
at 10:00, 9:00 Central
on Comedy Central.
And the wonderful,
magnanimous Fran Drescher.
Thank you, we'll be right back.
Thank you! Thank you!
(upbeat music)
(audience applause)
All season long, we're
highlighting hometowns
all across the country because
there's no place like home.
Next up, it's Seattle, Washington,
where Marlie and Anthony Love call home.
The Loves love Seattle,
and I have a feeling we're about to, also.
Watch this.
- Hey Drew, it's Anthony and Marlie,
and we're in front of Pike Place Market.
Located in our hometown
of Seattle, Washington.
- Drew, we love Seattle so much.
Not just because of the great
scenery and great coffee,
but there's some places that
mean so much to us personally.
- So, come with us and
let us show you around.
(upbeat music)
- We are at the iconic Space Needle.
A signature staple for
the Seattle skyline.
- Of course it's iconic,
but it's personal for us because
on my first trip to Seattle in 2015,
this was the spot
when we decided that we
were gonna move to Seattle.
- And now it just represents
the love that we have
for this city.
(upbeat music)
Welcome to Boon Boona Coffee.
Boon Boona is a local Seattle coffee shop
that specializes in African coffee.
- Before moving to Seattle,
we only drank the name brand stuff.
But locals told us, hey,
you have to try a local spot.
Boon Boona was the first
one, and we fell in love.
- Now that got some coffee,
let us take you to another
spot that is personal to us.
(upbeat music)
- We're in front of Alki Beach.
One of many beaches located
right here in Seattle.
- Yeah, there's so many
beautiful beaches in Seattle.
You really can't go wrong.
But Alki is our personal favorite.
Not only because it was the first beach
that we visited when we moved to Seattle,
but look at those breathtaking views.
- [Anthony] Also, visitors can
play volleyball, walk, run,
or ride on the paved path
laid along the beach.
- [Marlie] On top of all that,
right across from the
beach are great options
for food and fun.
With plenty of restaurants,
bars, and shops.
Alki Beach, another reason
why we love Seattle.
- Well Drew, that's just a snapshot
of this beautiful city of Seattle.
- We hope you love it as much as we do.
We can't wait for you to come visit!
See you soon.
- I love you, Loves!
And by the way, I never go to Seattle
without hitting Pike's Market
and having a bowl of the
best clam chowder ever.
Ah, what a wonderful place.
I love Seattle, and hometowns,
and I love this country.
(upbeat music)
(audience applause)
Hello, welcome back.
Our next guest became a
viral sensation on TikTok
for breaking into someone's home,
but it's not what you're thinking,
'cause we're not advocating that here.
He didn't actually take
anything from the house,
not even a little.
But he did leave it spotless,
after spending two and
a half hours cleaning it
from top to bottom.
Yeah, I know, this is such a wild story.
Check this out.
(upbeat music)
- So, my friend tells me
that one of his coworkers
wants me to clean his apartment.
So I go there today,
and he tells me that
there's a key under the mat.
Get the key, go into the apartment,
clean the entire apartment.
So he calls me and he's like,
yo, where are you?
And I was like, um,
I'm in your living room
waiting for you to walk in.
I'm playing with your cat.
He goes, "Man, I don't have a cat."
What?
So, comes to find out that I
cleaned the wrong apartment,
and broke in and cleaned
somebody's random apartment.
You're welcome?
(audience laughing)
- Please say hello to Louie Angelino!
(audience applause)
So, how did this happen?
- So, I was off by one digit.
It was only one number.
227 instead of 277.
And I had just assumed that I was going
to the right address.
But it just so happened that
there was two keys under both of the mats,
which is insane,
because what are the odds
that there's going to be two keys
on the same time in the same day
under both mats?
- How did you even get in
to the taking care of people's homes?
- To be completely honest,
with everything that happened with COVID,
I was feeling very uninspired,
and she's in the audience right now,
is my best friend, Jo Duran's mom,
and my mother are in the office.
- Oh hi!
(audience applause)
- That is them.
They are the ones that, my
mom, ever since I was a kid,
has always told me,
clean room, clean mind.
And Diana, who looks so lovely today,
told me, she came up with the idea
to pay me like 50 bucks a week
to just to keep the
apartment clean for her
and my best friend, and
started out with that.
And through doing that,
I would just, you know,
I would go in there with
my Bluetooth speaker,
and I'm jamming out and I'm dancing,
and I'm Swiffering, and
I'm having so much fun
I don't even realize that I'm cleaning.
I was at a very dark place at that time.
I didn't have a car, I didn't have a job.
I really didn't have a purpose.
And they gave me that.
- Thank you guys so much for
giving that type of advice
and direction and being
such positive influences.
And I want to celebrate
things like this in the world.
And you know, you have this new passion,
and you're gonna pursue this as a career?
- I would love to.
That would be the dream.
- Alright, well I know that you started
a GoFundMe page to help
kickstart your cleaning career,
and your giving, and your altruism,
and you're taking care of people,
and we just want to help you
continue that and foster that.
So our friends at Safely
are giving you $10,000
worth of Safely cleaning products.
(audience applause)
- Oh my gosh.
- And that is not only a
year's worth of supplies,
but we'd love to feature
you on our website,
and help build your business!
- Oh my god.
(audience applause)
- Thank you, yes.
- Where do I sign?
Where do I sign my soul to you?
- You already did.
- Oh girl.
Oh my god.
(audience laughing)
- You already did.
- Thank you so much.
It's really a big thing
for my mental health.
And like, that's one thing
I wanted to mention is that
I know everybody, somehow, someway,
battles with something
that goes on up here.
And if something as
keeping a clean environment
can help somebody like
me with mental health,
it can help out somebody else, too.
And that's just, that's
so important for me
because mental health, really,
finally I think we're at a point where
it's being taken seriously.
- Yeah.
I think athletes talking about it
is really amazing.
- Yes, yes.
- Because if they're saying they struggle,
I think there's a lack of bias sometimes,
or maybe a greater
openness to understanding
that even the strongest
people go through it.
But I think we also need
to hear from everybody
about how important that mission is.
I mean, I see you
building a whole business
that also recruits other people.
Like let's get this going, Louie.
All right?
- Yes. (laughing)
- Let's go, alright.
(audience applause)
- Let's go.
- Thank you, Louie.
Go on TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
to learn more
about Louie's amazing business,
and thank you for Safely giving
$10,000 to Louie's cause.
We'll be right back.
- Thank you.
- Thank you, Louie!
(audience applause)
(upbeat music)
Welcome back!
We are celebrating hometowns
all across the country,
all season long.
And this week, we're
loving on my new hometown,
New York City!
(audience applause)
I know!
Alright, well there's five boroughs,
and it feels almost impossible
to experience everything
that the city has to offer,
but that didn't stop us from trying,
one borough at a time.
I met up with my new bestie,
I am not kidding, Fat Joe.
(audience cheering)
Who's such a good human!
Oh my god, I see why
everybody worships him.
And he took me on a tour of
his native borough, The Bronx.
Let's take a look.
(upbeat music)
Hey everyone!
We're here in the Bronx,
with the Grammy-nominated musician,
entrepreneur, and Bronx native,
and he is about to take us on
the ultimate Bronx tour.
I just can't wait to meet him,
and I'm actually gonna meet him right now!
- Welcome to The Bronx.
(upbeat music)
- Fat Joe!
- I think I'm going to record this show,
and play that intro back
every morning for motivation.
- Where are we going first?
(upbeat music)
- This is the number one
entire bakery in the Bronx.
Let's go.
- Let's go.
I'm so excited.
(upbeat music)
Oh wow.
There's cookies with our faces on it.
- [Fat Joe] Shout out to
the staff of Artuso's.
- Oh my gosh!
- Yeah yeah yeah.
That's the biggest cannoli.
- That's called cannoli.
Believe it or not,
they specialize in all desserts.
The favorite thing of mine
here is birthday cakes.
- [Drew] Do we get to
try the birthday cake?
- B time!
- Oh my gosh. That is-
- This is beautiful.
Home is where you are, wow.
- You've been married 26 years.
- 26 years, yeah.
It's been real.
- Joe, give me a word of wisdom
about longevity in marriage.
- When you meet the person you love,
a switch goes off where
you say, this is it.
'Cause I had no money.
When I met her, I lived in an apartment,
and I only had a mattress.
And so we made a vow, I said listen,
if we get successful,
we're never gonna leave each other.
We're never gonna change on each other.
- Joe, there are so many things
I want to keep talking to you about.
Let's go to the next location,
and we'll pick another
profound dope subject.
- This guy is amazing.
We going to Jimmy's spot Con Sofrito
to give you that real, authentic,
you can't get realer than this.
(upbeat music)
Jimmy is a living legend.
He makes these recipes and mixes things up
that no one would ever think of
in the Latin community.
Now this is (speaking in foreign language)
It's a hearty soup.
- Like a Puerto Rican soup.
Yeah.
- Meat and starches
and root vegetables, I am so excited.
Okay here we go, you guys.
This is my very first bite.
- Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- How does, nah, stop, come on.
This is the best.
- Joe, my god.
- You gotta stop, Drew.
You know this is the best.
I've been collecting
sneakers my whole life.
20-something years.
And I said, we're about
to go to my newest store
that hasn't even, we're
gonna reveal it on your show,
it's called Up NYC The Bronx.
And let's get going over there.
- Break out the Klieg lights.
We have a premiere coming.
- [Fat Joe] So let's go.
(Drew screaming)
Voila. After you.
So this is the latest creation,
Up NYC, the third store.
We're in the South Bronx.
We wanted to do something really,
really beautiful for the community.
You know, a lot of people
who get successful,
whether they're famous
or they're entrepreneurs,
the dream is to leave the hood,
and most of them never come back.
The thing that I like,
is we create a hub, or a
safe place for the community,
showing that the future of entrepreneurs
and successful people
that come from the hood,
you can be successful, move out,
but you could come back
and just give inspiration
and give hope.
- I am really, like just,
insanely, overly impressed.
- Let me show you this room over here.
We have a learning center
for kids that don't have
access to computers.
Then I might have my
successful friends come
once a month and give them
a motivational for the kids.
And the projects right across the street.
So let me show you, Drew,
so you could see that this is real.
(upbeat music)
This is the projects, affordable housing,
across the street.
It's time that people
take our community serious
and invest back,
and show them the love that they need
and the support they need.
- What do you think attributes the most
to being such a good person?
- Just we done been
through so much in life
that we have no choice,
but God has blessed me and my family,
but to give back to my community
and just offer them hope or inspiration.
And I got something for you.
- [Construction Worker]
That's Drew Barrymore!
- Hi!
- That's Drew Barrymore.
In the hood.
- We love your show!
- Oh thank you, we love you too!
(laughing)
(men chattering)
- Number love, y'all.
These are some dunks called
New York versus New York.
All the street basketball
parks are down here.
It's just a gift from us to you, you know.
Up NYC, you know, 'cause we love you
and we thank you, appreciate you,
for all the love you're showing us.
- This is such a big deal
that I'm gonna get a pair of
sneakers from you right now.
(laughing)
I mean, I just can't.
It's like we're in England,
and I'm being knighted by the Queen.
- I mean, you've definitely
been knighted in the Bronx.
- Thank you for literally making me
the coolest person amongst my friends.
What do you think?
- Those are fly.
And they match.
(high five-ing)
- I'm gonna do-
(bell dinging)
- Oh...man.
- Oh Joe, I love you so much!
(audience applause)
I love you so much.
And Fat Joe, he hooked us
up with some cool sneakers.
So we thought we'd do
the same for all of you.
I mean, I have sneakers from Fat Joe.
I have so much cred now,
it's not even funny.
Alright, so everyone
in our studio audience
is gonna get a pair of Vessi shoes.
I know!
(audience cheering)
What's really cool about these
is their 100% waterproof.
Ooh, that's sexy in the city.
And vegan, which is also so good.
(audience applause)
And also, let's face facts.
I didn't wear these
shoes on a borough tour.
If you're gonna walk around New York,
do yourself a favor.
Wear something doable, comfortable,
and stylish.
And go to any neighborhood that you want
and enjoy yourself, and
we'll be right back.
Thank you Vessi!
(upbeat music)
Thank you Joe!
(audience applause)
(upbeat music)
(indistinct chattering)
Welcome back!
It's time for Drew's News,
your scrappy little good news program,
just trying to make it in a big city.
And with me at the desk,
(Ross laughing)
my fierce and trusty co-pilot,
Ross Mathews.
- We're back!
Hi, everybody.
(audience applause)
- The first New York audience!
Well, it's good to be at home,
but we can't get too comfortable,
'cause we're taking our
little new show on the road
later this week.
We're Drew's News-ing from Philly.
- [Ross] Hey Philly!
We're coming!
- Uh huh, yeah.
Maybe some cheese steaks.
- Oh please, please.
- And then, we're also coming
from our nation's capitol,
Washington DC.
It's so epic.
- Yeah.
We have a news desk, we will travel.
So if you want us to come to your city,
hit us up on social media.
Maybe you'll see us right there.
- That's right. Have desk, will travel.
Hit us up.
Please welcome us,
(audience laughing)
or request us in your city.
(audience applause)
We will show up.
- I can't wait for Philly and DC.
- I know, I know.
- Yeah.
- Well, there's no better
way to kick off this news
than with one of the biggest superstars
in digital comedy right now.
He's got millions of
followers on Instagram
who are absolutely hooked on
his incredible characters.
He recently took his talents
to Washington as well.
Here's a look at Benito Skinner.
- Hey everyone.
Vogue!
Usually I start off with a big coffee.
Sorry, they're like really strict in here.
Hey Jenny, I booked you
a nail appointment, love.
- Yeah, I didn't tell you to do that.
- It's called initiative.
(laughing)
Hi, White House, this is Cooper.
Mm, I don't think so.
Oh, doesn't matter.
(patriotic music)
Oh thank you, honey.
These suck.
Surfion XCX, put on Chem Trails.
Anastasia, get out here for
your swim lesson, honey.
(audience applause)
- Please welcome back to the show,
Benito Skinner, AKA Benny Drama.
- What?
(audience applause)
Literally, like, I'm in heaven.
- [Drew] Oh my god,
you're the biggest deal in the world.
- Oh stop.
- Oh I can't.
I will never, ever.
- Drew, Drew.
- And by the way, I posted
your video that you did.
You do Danielle from "Ever After,"
the film I was in.
And your Danielle is everything!
- That movie is my favorite movie ever.
The wings!
No, it was my fantasy.
- Give me one
line as Danielle.
- Oh my god.
Well I think I have to do just like,
breathe, just breathe.
(audience laughing)
It was, no...
That was my fantasy come to life.
I mean, yeah, it was an honor.
- [Drew] Alright, well
let's jump in to the news.
- Hey, oh, we gotta talk about this.
You know, we're back in the city,
and all summer long,
the talk of the town has been,
"Sex and the City."
Are you ready?
SJP, Cynthia Nixon, and Kristin Davis,
they're shooting the HBO Max spinoff,
"And Just Like That,"
which is what it's called.
And Vanity Fair reports you can get all
the leaked info you need
on Instagram and online.
There have been tons of photos
of the ladies on set,
revealing new cast members,
like Nicole Ari Parker,
and shots of Carrie in bed with Mr. Big.
And, okay, I feel torn about this,
because I am looking forward to this
more than anything I've ever
looked forward to in my entire life.
And I feel like, about these leaks,
they feel like dessert for me.
You know?
Like I devour it, and then I just feel bad
about my choices.
(audience laughing)
Because I want to wait.
I want to see the whole
thing when it comes out.
Thoughts?
- No, so, okay.
I also devour it.
It's kind of like, if music leaks,
and I'm like, I can't touch that.
The artist wouldn't want me to.
And I'm like, play it again.
(audience laughing)
- [Drew] Alright well
your story next, Benny.
- Oh my God, my turn.
Next, we're gonna talk about
the latest dating term on, this one,
wait, how do you guys do this?
(audience laughing)
This is so stressful!
I feel like I'm in fifth grade
and I have to read in front of the class.
- By the way, if someone told me, like,
just come up with a
character out of thin air,
I would feel the same way.
So, trust, go.
- Yeah, okay.
Okay my turn.
Next, we're gonna talk about the latest
dating term on the block.
Why am I reading this like that?
Roaching.
(audience laughing)
Like, literally, I'm Kris Jenner.
- [Drew] 'Cause this
is your news character.
- InStyle reports.
Roaching refers to when
the person you're dating
is sleeping with a ton of other people,
and not telling you about it.
That's also called
being a horrible person.
It's a really simple thing you could say.
If you know of even just one person
he's hooking up with other than you,
get out the Raid, spray it.
Ross, Drew.
(audience laughing)
Have you ever been roached?
- Oh, well, I mean, I just assume.
Here's the deal.
I think, unless you're exclusive,
you're not exclusive, you know?
So you should just assume
you're getting roached.
And ironically, it doesn't bug me.
I think-
(audience laughing)
- [Drew] Pun intended!
- Yes, totally intended.
- Yes.
- I just think until you
have that convo of like,
you and me and no one else, right?
You just should sort of
just accept the facts,
'cause they gettin' it.
- But I do like when new vernacular
comes into our zeitgeist,
and we can now say, "Oh,
she's roaching, he's a roach."
I think that's fun.
- I think it's fun too.
And honestly, it has the right tenor.
Like, the tone for what you're doing.
You are roaching.
- Yeah, like you're vile.
You're a roach.
- But we have something
else to do, though.
I'm very excited because
we built a brand new digital studio.
It's upstairs.
It is stunning, it is gorgeous.
It's fun.
- [Ross] How cool.
- It's giving you MTV and the 80's vibes.
And we are so lucky because Benny,
you are gonna be our very first.
You're gonna christen it,
and we are gonna do it together.
So thank you for doing the inaugural
digital piece with us.
(audience applause)
- Of course, I love that.
Oh my god! Yes yes yes!
- And he's got a character,
and we're going for it.
We'll be right back!
(upbeat music)
(audience applause)
Welcome back!
Okay, it's almost time to go,
but we couldn't be more thrilled
and truly honored to be back
in our hometown of New York City.
And it is a big moment, yes.
(audience applause)
I heart New York, indeed.
And we've got someone special here
to help us celebrate.
He is a musician,
and someone that you must follow right now
in The Doggy Bag.
(chiming music)
(dog barks)
(Ross barking)
There he goes.
He's added a very rich
soundtrack of the city
as a street performer for many years
with a sax that could
just stop your heart.
Please welcome Augie Bello!
- [Ross] Augie!
(audience applause)
- How are you guys?
- Augie, welcome.
- Thank you so much.
I'm so excited to be here.
- We're so excited you're here.
- Thank you so much.
- You bring so much joy.
What's your favorite part
of doing what you do?
- So, with every morning I wake up,
trying to make someone smile.
And if I can do that through music,
or through making someone laugh,
then that's a day worth living for me.
- Oh come on.
(audience awing)
(Drew weeping dramatically)
(audience laughing)
You broke her!
- Ah, it hurts!
It hurts!
This is what it is,
this is the good stuff.
This is worth the search,
'cause these are the
rewards, is someone like you.
- [Augie] Thank you so much.
That means the world to me.
- [Drew] Augie, thank you.
- Of course.
- For being here, everybody,
thank you for being here.
(audience applause)
Rossy, I love you.
Augie, take it away.
(saxophone music)
(audience cheering and clapping)
(cheering and clapping)
(music resumes)
(gentle tones)
(musical flourish)
(upbeat music)